a tan solo unos 30 km de la frontera con
rusia
la ciudad de kharkiv continúa sitiada y
atacada por las fuerzas de moscú
el impacto de misiles rusos incendió
esta plaza de mercado
vi humo negro y supe que el mercado para
abajo estaba en llamas
viene a intentar recuperar los productos
frescos costo por
estado
no hubo víctimas mortales a diferencia
de en este otro mercado donde murieron
tres personas un día antes
las tropas rusas atacan la segunda mayor
ciudad de ucrania desde el flanco norte
y este pero la determinación y
resistencia ucraniana están frenando la
ofensiva de moscú
el ejército ucraniano lleva tres semanas
defendiendo sus posiciones y en
consecuencia las tropas rusas están
redefiniendo su despliegue
konstantín piloto retirado de la fuerza
aérea ucraniana ha regresado a filas
para luchar por su país sabe que jarquín
es un punto estratégico para la invasión
rusa
esta es la primera línea de defensa de
la ciudad
[Música]
creas tu hija
si la atraviesan entrarán en kharkiv
esta carretera te lleva desde rusia al
corazón de la ciudad
a pesar de las difíciles condiciones de
vida cientos de miles de personas
permanecen en la ciudad
les estoy muy agradecida por defender
nuestra tierra
entre más aguanten chicos siempre les
apoyaremos
mis dos hijas y una de mis nietas están
luchando por ucrania
las autoridades ucranianas cifran en 500
las personas muertas en kharkiv desde el
principio de la invasión rusa